مساء الخير معال الدكتور مساء النور اهلا
وسهلا البرنامج النووي الايراني محل قل
للدول الجوار لايران سواء عربيه او غير
عربيه والموقف السعودي انه الرسمي اذا
وصلت ايران للقنبله النوويه فسوف نطور
برنامجا نوويا عسكريا والرئيس التركي تحدث
منذ سنتين او ثلاثه عن طموح او عن اسفه
لعدم تمكن تركيا من تطوير سلاح نووي سؤالي
الحقيقه بسيط جدا لح حضرتك فنيا هل تستطيع
هذه الدول تطوير قدرات نوويه متطوره
ولنبدا بالسعوديه اللي هي المتضرره الاكبر
من البرنامج النووي الايراني هو ايه
الامكانيات النوويه اللي موجوده في
السعوديه حتى الان السعوديه لا يوجد لديها
اي امكانيات نوويه ولا منشات نوويه ا ولا
مواد ذات قيمه عندها مواد صغيره قوي لدرجه
انه الاتفاق الضمانات وهو التفتيش المفتش
الوكاله واخ وقعته قريب يعني ما كانتش
يعني مؤيده توقيعه لان ما كانش عندها حاجه
الا يعني من فتره زمنيه بسيطه ووقعت اتفاق
مش الاتفاق العام للضمانات اللي هو بينطبق
على الدول اللي عندها امكانيات نوويه
كبيره لا اتفاقيات الضمانات على انها دوله
لا تستعمل المواد النوويه الا بشكل محدود
للغايه
ا طيب ده معناه ايه معناه انه السعوديه
لسه ما عندهاش اي برنامج واضح قوي منشات
واضحه مواد نوويه واضحه يعني يعني
السعوديه لسه بعيده قوي لكن هل السعوديه
بتفكر في الاستمرار او هل هي مش هي بعيده
عن البرامج النوويه لا السعوديه بتفكر
بقوه وهي اعلنتها هي مهتمه جدا
بستخدام الطاقه النوويه في انتاج الكهرباء
وتحليه المياه بصوره
خاصه البندين دول السعوديه بدات تفكر في
انواع متطوره من المفاعلات النوويه تعاقدت
في الفتره الاخيره مع شركه كوريا من كوريا
الجنوبيه لدراسه اقامه مفاعلين نوويين
صغار القدره 100 ميجا
وات بيفكر ان هي تنشئها في في عندها بدات
تفكر زي ما كثير من دول المنطقه دي اللي
هي بيكثر فيها خام اليورانيوم انها تبحث
على خام اليورانيوم وحديثا عملت اتفاق مع
الصين
لاكتشاف مناجم اليورانيوم الخام هو قيل
بعد كده ان عملوا اتفاق على
تصنيع الكعكه الصفراء من هذا اليورانيوم
لكن في الواقع الكلام ده نفي و مش منطقي
قوي انه يتعاقد دلوقتي وهو لسه اصلا
مالقاش يورانيوم هو متوقع وجود يورانيوم
في المنطقه اذا حضرك بتقول المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في المراحل المبكره جدا
هل ايه اهم المنشات النوويه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه المعلن عنها هو حتى الان
في مركز البحوث وللعلوم
والتكنولوجيا في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
دي بتهتم اساسا بالطاقه النوويه النظيفه
سواء الجديده او المتجدده منها الطاقه
النوويه وطاقه الشمس والرياح دي البلد
اللي بتركز فيها هذه الابحاث لكن حتى الان
لا يوجد مفاعل ابحاث واحد في السعوديه
النهارده لما ابتدي اقول ان دوله ممكن
تستطيع ان هي تطور برنامج نووي سلمي اولا
العسكري دي قصه تانيه هي مش ليها ابجديات
يعني مثلا الدوله دي لازم يكون لها قاعده
صناعيه لازم يكون عندها عدد متخصصين كتير
في السلاح النووي لازم يكون فييه بنيه
تحتيه انت حضرتك بخبرتك عشرات السنين اللي
فاتت دي لما تبص لدوله تقول دي دوله
تستطيع ان تنمي قدرات نوويه هي ان ارادت
بشكل سريع انا بتكلم على السلم الاول
وعدنا العسكري ده اراده سياسيه ايه هي
الشروط اولا يكون عندي صناعه فنيه متقدمه
صناعه في ايه بقى انا انا محتاج
ا للتصنيع اولا تصنيع الماده ماده الوقود
نفسها اللي هي اليورين عندي مصانع لتصنيع
الوقود مصانع طبعا لو انا زي ما بقول لك
احنا عندنا كذا اختيار الاختيار بتاع
اليورانيوم يبقى انا لازم يكون عندي مصانع
تقدر تصنع وحدات التخصيب الدواره اللي
بتلف دي عشان تطلع لي اليورانيوم عالي
التخصيب ده لازم يكون عندي مصانع متقدمه
هتصنع لي ده زي ايران دلوقتي ما هي
بتصنعها في المصانع واغلبها بيكون مصانع
عربيه عاي يكون عندي ده هي تقدر
اعملها عندي صناعه تحويل اليورانيوم من
يورانيوم ا مسحوق اليورانيوم الى يورانيوم
غازي اللي هو من الكعكه الصفراء الى
الكعكه الصفراء للتركيز بتاعها الى
اليورانيوم هيكسا فلورايد بصوره خاصه لكن
ممكن يكون تترا فلورايد اللي هو يو اف 4
لو انا عايز اخش في الميتال تمام لو مش
هخش في الميتال زي
كوريا الشماليه وصنعت المفاعل بتاعها يبقى
احتاجت اليو اف 4 لونه اخضر كده شويه
وبتاع فاذا محتاج هذه الصناعه محتاج لهذه
الاجهزه اللي بتعمل عمليات التحويل بعد
كده تصنيع الوقود زي ما قلت قبل كده انا
في بعض الانواع زي لو انا هعمل غازي
جرافيتي زي كوريا الشماليه بعمل يوريني
ميتال رودز ان انا اصنع هذه الردز
نفسها اذا كان جرافايت يبقى صنع الجرافات
اذا كان ماء ثقيل صنع الماء الثقيل زي
ايران ما عملت دلوقتي في عندها مصنع ماء
ثقيل ديدي يبقى قاعده صناعيه مرتبطه
بالتقديم على ما يحتاجه البرنامج النوي
الاجزاء زائد قاعده عسكريه متقدمه و بصوره
خاصه في كان انا هدف قاعده صناعيه عسكريه
عسكريه اه ويكون متقدمه يعني مثلا اتكلمنا
احنا في العراق ان كان
عندهم تطور كبير في مجال المتفجرات وادوات
التفجير
ونجحوا طبعا في بعض المواقع اللي عندهم
هناك انهم يجربوا هذا التفج وده سعدهم ايه
ان هم كان عندهم بنيه تحتيه قويه
للمتفجرات التقليديه فبدا يطورها ويقول لك
طب انا عايز المتفجرات دي تبقى بالشكل ده
اللي يصلح للقنابل الذريه فدي برده اداه
تانيه رقم لاثه الثلاثه اللي هي الديليفري
اللي اتكلمنا عليها برده اللي هي ازاي
ادوات التوصيل اوصل القنبله انا هوصل ف
طبعا الصواريخ هي اسهل حاجه والطيران ممكن
فلازم يكون عندي صناعه صواريخ بس ممكن
استور صواريخ لا الصاروخ مش الصاروخ
العاديه دي ما ينفعش لازم صاروخ مواصفات
معينه وده الكلام الكتير كان عن ايران
انها
بتطور لاثه انه يقدر يشيل ما يقرب من طن
اه لازم الصواريخ فمحتاجه للتطوير ده
الكلام ده برض كان بيت انا اقصد يعني من
خبره حضرتك انا عارف انه مش مكانك يصعب ان
دوله تستورد هذا النوع من الصواريخ بيبقى
عليه ق بيبقى في تعاون بيبقى في تعاون مع
دول اخرى ممكن يعني يعني طبعا انت عارف ان
كوريا الشماليه مثلا في
ا بالذات اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه خايفين
قوي منها عشان الصواريخ لان طورت التاج
الصواريخ بتاعتها لقدرات عاليه جدا لا هي
طورت عندها قدرات ذاتيه لكن دوله بتب لا
مش ذاتيه الكوريه الشماليه اقوللك مش
ذاتيه بس مش هتكلم كتير عنيده طيب اذا
فانا محتاج قاعده عسكريه سواء تصنع
لي وسائل التفجير او كمان صناعه عسكريه
عشان تصنع لي الصواريخ اللي ممكن تنقل هذه
النقل وسيله نقل القنابل الذريه الق رقم
اربعه هنتكلم على العلماء والفنيين لازم
يكون عندي قاعده طبعا طبعا لازم يكون عندي
ناس بتفهم لازم اكون الناس دي دربتها
واخذت خبره وده اللي حصل يعني يمكن العراق
وايران ودول امثله على الناس دي اللي راحت
واخدت خبرات كبيره ليبيا الى حد مامكن
اتكلم عليها نفس كلام باكستان طبعا والهند
انا بسال حضرتك السؤال ده ليه لانه كان من
حوالي كم سنه لما صار الغرب بيحب يتكلم عن
السعوديه كتير الاسباب يعني ممكن يطول
شرحها ولكن دايما الكلام انه السعوديه
نتيجه ان هي الاكثر تضررا من ايران يعني
هل هي ممكن تطور قنبله نوويه ولا لا كان
في جدل بين بعض اكبر الكتاب يعني في
الولايات المتحده بعضهم بيقول تستطيع
السعوديه او اي دوله اخرى ان هي تطور
قنبله نوويه فيرد عليه واحداني يقول له
ازاي البلد هتصنع قنبله نوويه وهي لا تصنع
سياره فيرد عليه طرف اخر ويقول له طب ما
باكستان ما كانش بتصنع سياره ولكنها صنعت
قنبله نوويه ففي جدل انت راي حضرتك ايه لا
لا لا ما فيش مناقشه احنا لو هتكلم على
باكستان باكستان دوله الطاقه الذريه
بتاعتها انشات من عشرات السنين باكستان
كان عندها مراكز ابحاث نوويه هي والهند
على فكره نس الكلام ا كتيره كان عندها
مفاعلات ابحاث وبعد كده جت مفاعلات قوى ا
كهربيه وبعدين هي بنفسها وبالتعاون مع بعض
الدول الغربيه بدات تنشئ مصانع للتخصيب
خفيف يعني علىق صغير لحد ما عبد القدير
خان جا رجع وجاب معاه كل الوسائل ان هم
يصنعوا الوحدات التقصيب بالذات السنترفيوج
وجاب معاه برض بعض الرسومات
لتصميمات القنابل الزاريه والى اخره فاذا
لا انا لا يمكن اقارن ايران بغيرها يعني
قصدي ل
مافيش دوله هتقدر تطور برنامجها النووي
العسكري الا لو كان عندها قدرات وبنيه
تحتيه قويه جدا صناعيه اه مدنيه صناعيا
وفنيا وماديا طبعا لان البرنامج العراقي
ده كلف ارقام خرافيه اه وايران كمان طبعا
تكلف حاجات تانيه ولكن نفرق بقى هو انا
اقدر القنبله الذريه في بلد اجيبها ازاي
يا اما انا اعملها يا اما اشتريها من بره
اه لحد النهارده على مدى التاريخ بتاعنا
كله ما فيش دوله اهدت او
باعت قنبله ذريه زي ما هي كده لدوله تانيه
ماثرتش على مستوى العالم كله حتى يمنى هذا
لكن حصل بعض المساعدات زي مساعده فرنسا
لاسرائيل في مركز ديموه لانه اكيد هم
كانوا عارفين ان المفاعلات دي قد تؤدي في
الاخر الى سلاح نووي فرنسا بدون قصد يعني
ساعدت العراق في مفاعلين الفرنسيين اللي
هم
ادوه رغم انه هي العراق يعني ما كانش واضح
ابدا ولحد الان ما كانش عارف ان المفاعلين
دول كانوا يستخدموا استخدام عسكري ولا لا
كان يعني ما كانش فيه لكن اللي عايز اقوله
كقنبلة
ريه والبتاع ده لم تثبت حتى الان كل ما في
الامر اللي اه ثبت انه كان في هناك افراد
في باكستان كانوا
بيبيعوا اجزاء او تصميمات لدول اخرى اه دي
ثبت واتحقق فيها وثبت الاتهام فيها اذا
فكل الكلام اللي قيل عن انه احتمال انه
باكستان فكرت في فتره من الفترات ان تبيع
قنبله للمملكه العربيه السعوديه او لليبيا
هذا كلام عاريا عن الصحه عاريا عن الصحه
ولكن لا يمنع ان السعوديه ساعدت الباكستان
مساعدات ماديه
ا قويه
وان اتخيل اليوم اللي كان اذا كان اسرائيل
مثلا هتستخدم سلاح نووي
ضد سعوديه مثلا لا كان هيبقى كذا دوله
نوويه اخرى هيكون لها موقف ضد اسرائيل قد
تكون منها باكستان وقد تكون روسيا وقد
تكون الصين حتى
ف يعني مش مش بالبساطه لكن ما حصلش ابدا
ان في الدوله ثبت ان هي باعت قنبله ذريه
لدوله ثانيه كان في في الماركت في السوق
يمكن اكلمت مره قبل كده انه كان في عرض
لبعض القنابل الذريه او صور لقنابل الذريه
انها بتتباع بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
وسبيت كلها انها كاذبه عا حضرك سؤال يبدو
مدرسي شويه احنا طبعا احنا اتكلمنا في
الحلقات اللي فاتت انه الدول العربيه في
دول معينه في المنطقه العربيه ضمن مجموعه
اخرى عندها قدرات نوويه بدرجات مختلفه من
التطور لكن انا هاخد احنا كنا بنتكلم على
السعوديه ون استانف من السعوديه انت حضرتك
قلت ان السعوديه لم تبدا برنامجا نوويا
متطورا ولما بتتكلم على برنامج نووي انا
اقصد سلمي اولا بديه انه يبدا سلمي
بلد زي السعوديه والبلاد المماثله اذا
ارادت ان هي تبدا برنامجا سلميا وتطوره
بقدرتها تحتاج كم سنه تقريبا في المتوسط
من البدايه دي من الموقف اللي في السعوديه
عشان يبقى عندها برنامج وقدرات نوويه
سلميه متطوره اولا تحتاج الى كم سنه اتخيل
في حدود 10 سنين تستطيع من الان 10 سنين
يبقى عندها مفاعلات نوويه او عندها يعني
ابحاث وحدات تخصيب كل الحاجات دي يعني اذا
سمح لها العالم يعني هي النهارده لو هتقول
انا عايز اعمل مفاعل زي اراك مفاعل اراك
بتاع الماء
الثقيل اكيد ده انت شفت
موضوع اليورانيوم الخام والضجه اللي حصلت
عليه ايه تخيل بقى ان السعوديه تقول طب
انا عايز اعمل مفاعل ابحاث 40 ميجا وات ما
سقيل لا يعني طب لكن لو دخلنا في مجال
الطاقه السلميه
الكهربا زي
الامارات طبعا البرنامج ده هيخ لله فتره
زمنيه بعد كده هل ان انا اقدر احول
الاستخدام السلمي لمفاعلات
سلميه للكهرباء
الى مفاعلات غير سلميه بحط كوشن مارك
و يعني مش هنتكلم في التفاصيل في الموضوع
قصه انيه لكن المفروض لا المفروض ما هو
خاضع لرقابه الوكاله ا عمليه انه استغلال
او خداع العالم ب من خلال المفاعلات
النوويه وخداع الوكاله ا وهي بتفتش
ومفتشين وان انا بستخدمها استخدام غير
سلمي هيبقى عمليه صعبه للغايه يعني هو
اللي احنا اللي تعلمناه من حضرتك واللي
بنتابع يعني انه اي دوله تستطيع ان هي
يكون عندها برنامج نووي سلمي متطور تستطيع
ان ار ان ارادت ان هي تحوله الى برنامج
عسكري ولكن هذه قصه اخرى بدليل ان اليابان
مثلا او المانيا تحرك مره قلت لي رقم مخيف
قلت لي اليابان تستطيع ان هي تنتج قنبله
ان ارادت خلال اسبوع صحيح ان ارادت فانت
حضج بتتكلم ان بلد ما عندوش قدرات نوويه
تذكر زي المملكه العربيه السعوديه تحتاج
10 سنوات عشان يكون عندها برنامج اه ا
تطويره عسكري دي قصه اخرى يحتاج قد ايه من
الاموال لو هبدا من سكراتش وابدا في حدود
انت حضرتك قلت لي ارقام متضاربه بس احنا
دلوقتي عندنا اه لا انا انا ممكن اتكلم
على
ارقام تتراوح بين 50 ل 100 مليار دولار اه
علشان يبقى عندي برنامج ولا عشان انطي
قنبله لا لو هي ما هو السؤال انا مش انطي
قنبله واحده يعني لا انا بقول القنبله
الاولى طبعا هي اللي غاليه لكن القنبله
الثانيه ممكن تاخدها ببلاش استاذنك نستانف
الحديث عن بعض هذه الدول في حلقات اخرى ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله